пане Порошенко ми знаємо що ви не
визнаєте так звані референдуми на сході
України але що ви скажете людям у
Донецьку та Луганську які бачать це
голосування як вихід із війни які просто
хочуть повернутися до нормального життя
по-перше це точно не Референдум
це не було виявлення народу тому що
неможливо організувати референдум Ось
так протягом 48 годин
погляньмо наприклад на досвід Швейцарії
нормальний референдум готується протягом
кількох місяців або років
балансу ЄС по-друге Я абсолютно
впевнений що Конституційний суд України
чинить так само як і під час свого
президентства з 2014 році щодо Криму
це однозначно антиконституційно
і по-третє Це російський трюк
його мета узаконити присутність своїх
військ і навіть нанести удар можливо
ядерний з території яку захопив Путін на
цьому фейковому референдумі
ви переймайтесь через ядерний удар Як
думаєте наскільки він імовірний
дивіться Путін божевільний маньяк він
абсолютно неадекватний
він думає що має лише один інструмент як
виправити ситуацію це шантаж
Він використовує безпековий шантаж коли
нападає на Україну використовує
енергетичний шантаж
і всі в Німеччині та в світі знають що
це означає з іншим шантажує зимовими
морозами і холодом блокуючи українське
порти тепер він використовує ядерний
шантаж
аварію на Запорізький АЕС і ядерним
ударом
у цій ситуації Я хочу нагадати що такий
самий шантаж був коли Україна
добровільно відмовилася від третього за
величиною ядерного Арсеналу у світі
як ми можемо реагувати тільки одним
способом
не використає ядерну зброю якщо захід
однозначно підтвердить що відповідь у
випадку удару буде жорсткою
безпосередньо щодо Путіна
Це був би акт самогубство Путіна
скільки він боїться цього сценарію Це
єдиний спосіб як ми можемо зупинити його
має бути спільна заява всіх ядерних
держав світу про те що реакція на напад
буде швидкою та рішучою
ми в Україні не боїмося їхньої ядерної
атаки незважаючи на те що якщо Путін
застосує ядерну зброю то першим пунктом
стане Київ
я перебуваю тут
сім місяців тому коли російський танки
стояли за 5 кілометрів від цього місця
солдати могу батальйону були на
передовій вірні
Сьогодні ми їх не боїмося і це не врятує
дупу Путіна
зустрічалися з Володимиром Путіним коли
були президентом як вважаєте наскільки
він змінився
У мене є кілька важливих рекомендацій з
власного досвіду переговорів з Путіним
по-перше будь ласка не бійтеся Путіна
якщо він відчує слабкість то зайде так
далеко як ми разом дозволимо йому зайти
по-друге не довіряйте Путіну Путіну
переговорах ніколи не дотримується свого
слова
по-третє Путін розуміє лише силу
і тому сила української армії
єдність українського суспільства та
народу і сильна єдина коаліція у світі
на підтримку України
безперечно зупинять Путіна
Саме тому він використав зараз механізм
призову до армії
механізм ядерного шантажу це небезпечно
і для нього і для його оточення
український уряд неодноразово просив в
Німеччину наприклад поставити її сучасні
бойові танки але канцлер олафшольц
наполягає на тому що такі кроки мають
бути узгодженим між союзниками І що
жодна інша країна не відправляла західні
бойові танки в Україну чи зрозуміла вам
ця позиція
насамперед я хочу подякувати державам
членам НАТО за вирішальну роль у
підтримці українських збройних сил
української держави
без такої підтримки дати відсіч Путіну
було б практично неможливо по-друге
поставка танків - це ініціатива партії
хдс
яка має погляди близькі до наших
я дещо розчарований тим що німецький
парламент буде Стах не підтримав цю
ініціативу
Я дуже сподівався на Це
по-третє ви повинні розуміти
що більше зброї що більше боєприпасів ви
постачаєте то коротшим буде шлях до миру
іншого шляху не існує Путін не розуміє
Ні компромісів Ні того що час дипломатії
закінчився
зараз найкращий дипломат - Це
український збройні сили за підтримки
союзників
і у цій ситуації безумовно Нам потрібні
німецькі танки
німецькі боєприпаси
Ми дуже вдячні за німецьку артилерію
нам не потрібні До речі німецькі солдати
Допоможіть нам врятувати вас
Допоможіть нам урятувати Європу
Допоможіть нам зробити нашу спільну
справу
оце точно була б німецька
відповідальність ідеючи танки України
підтримуючи Українські збройні сили ви
не лише допомагаєте Україні ви
інвестуєте у свою власну безпеку
з нами був колишній Президент України
Петро Порошенко щиро дякую вам
радий спілкуванню дякую